hi i'm maria i'm a tasty producer today
i've been challenged to take a common
food
and make it fancy as a friendly reminder
you can get this shirt or other merch
shopmakerfancy.com let's see what we are
making fancy today
oreos i have cooked with this before
a few times cookie is a little bit
bitter it's not too sweet
and the cream is you know sweet side so
it's actually very
well balanced cookie it's round so it's
cute
because anything round is cute it's been
a while since i had oreo last time so
let's try
smells nice like cocoa powder and they
are saying they are using real cocoa i
like to eat like break half and eight
okay nice and crispy
so a tasty we've used oreo
a lot but what i have in my mind is
pretty ambitious
so it could be very difficult i'm
worried it might not work
but as always i'm excited to make it
fancy
all right here's what i got butter milk
heavy cream
whole milk sour cream butter white
chocolate
dark chocolate and eggs from the pantry
i got
vegetable oil cake flour powdered sugar
all-purpose flour sugar instant coffee
cocoa powder baking soda baking powder
vanilla extract salt and kahlua
alright let's get started
make it fancy
first we are going to start with about
12
oreos i'm going to separate scrape the
cream part
if you don't have offset spatula you can
just use
butter knife or a knife cream comes off
pretty easily
it's tempting not to eat it grind up the
cookie part if you don't have
food processor you can just put in a
ziploc bag
and top it with rolling pin or wine
bottle
we have the oreo in japan i never
seen fan flavors in japan but i went to
museum of failure in los angeles a few
years ago and i saw
wow full of failed oreo flavors
and one of them was swedish fish but
some of them looks really nice like
cinnamon roll so final texture should
look like a
sand sift ground up oreo
so it doesn't have a big chunk i have
two and a quarter cup
all-purpose flour one cup and two
tablespoons of
cocoa powder and shift three cup of
sugar
one and a half teaspoon of baking powder
one tablespoon of baking soda one and a
half teaspoon of salt
gently mix so my dry ingredients
is ready i'm gonna set aside i have
three eggs
just loosen this up one and a half
teaspoon of vanilla
two tablespoons of kaluga and if you
don't want to use
alcohol you don't need to use it but
i like using alcohol yes so i
use kalua i have one and a half cup of
coffee
coffee kind of gives nice adult flavor
and
one and a half cup of buttermilk
i think some country doesn't have
buttermilk
if you don't have buttermilk in your
country
you can use milk and you can squeeze
a little bit of lemon juice three and a
quarter cup of vegetable oil
just mix well mix wet
ingredients to dry ingredients
you can just pour everything at once
this
is a recipe i used to use
when i was working at the restaurant
it's pretty
good recipe so i highly recommend you
guys to make it at home
we didn't use oreo it smelled so good i
think the smell
of oreo powder and coffee
and cocoa powder is very rich and
this is smell very fancy the nice thing
about glass bowl you can see if it's not
under mix so this is done i'm gonna set
aside
i have 8 by 2 inch cake pan
i have three of them for the parchment
paper
are making origami and flip the cake pan
find the center cut
straight and you have perfect circle
cake lining spray the pan put the
parchment paper
and make sure to spray
on the side pour butter to each pan
evenly divided we are going to bake this
at 350 fahrenheit
about 25 to 30 minutes or
you can poke this with toothpick and if
it comes out cleanly it's ready we have
plenty more oils to use so let's get to
it i
have 12 oreos this in a
food processor so this one i don't
separate
just use it as this
set this aside six cup of powdered sugar
and i'm going to shift it so the texture
is same as the last time it's almost
like a
sand three sticks of softened butter
it's unsalted add pinch of salt
half teaspoon of vanilla this is a
leftover oreo cream from
cake mixture add that 3 tablespoon of
cream
and blend until smooth texture
one side of powdered sugar i'm doing
in a small budget because if you add
at once the powder should fly everywhere
and
you're gonna make a mess in the kitchen
looks good
i'm gonna add the last batch
fold this oreo powder in a buttercream
you can see nice oreo speckle in a
buttercream
oreo is very versatile oreo can be used
for
cheesecake bottom oil can be used in ice
cream
oreo can be used in a pancake a lot of
transformation
but i'm not making any of those
okay i'm ready to move on i have two
and a half cup of cake flour half
teaspoon of baking soda 2 teaspoon
of baking powder 1 teaspoon of salt
again we are mixing dry ingredients
first
and set aside 5 eggs and i'm going to
separate
use each shell and kind of
move back and forth so for this cake we
are not gonna use egg yolks we're gonna
just use egg whites
i have one stick and half butter
one three quarter cups of sugar and
cream them together about two minutes
and add egg whites mix them about two
minutes
and i have half cup sour cream mix until
well combined
when you're using baking soda you need
some active agent
if you don't use it you kind of have
metallic flavor that baking soda has
add dry ingredients at once
okay and then add one cup of milk
okay looks good you're gonna spray the
pan
at the cake liner spray again
make sure you spray on the side then
pour
this kind of look like android blood if
you know you know
so we are going to bake this at high
about 25 to 30 minutes
if you are not sure if it's baked
through you can use the two speakers
again
so so far it's a little bit simple but
next step is gonna be more ambitious
20 grams of flour 3 grams of
powdered sugar 5 gram of crumbled oreo
and add pinch of salt mix well
quarter cup of water and quarter cup
of oil and mix well i already preheated
pan over medium high heat pour
butter using little you want to make
sure pine's hot you see this like
nice bubble i'm going to flip this
once outside looks dry it's ready
and you're gonna just put it on top of
the paper towel
so this cookie should look like lazy
and look like almost like coral and you
don't need to make
perfect circle if it's kind of abstract
to shape
it's also really cool so this is what i
was going for this is something very
crispy not like a pancake or crepes
breaks easily it's like a cookie
nice and crunchy i'm going to finish the
rest of the butter
and move on to next step and i'm going
to use more oreos
i have 12 oreos put it in a ziploc
you just wanted to make rough chunks
like pebble so i have 12 oils
each white chocolate and dark chocolate
i'm going to microwave every 30 seconds
until completely melted and i'll be
right back
chocolate is melted pour chocolate over
parchment lined baking sheet and
spread evenly if you don't have a
spatula you can use spoons knife
or rubber spatula sprinkle
this oreo bits do the same with
dark chocolate and spread nice and even
again
and sprinkle oreo bits and you
want to do this before chocolate it set
so oreo sticks this is super easy cool
dessert you can put
other stuff like pretzels and stuff i'm
going to put this in the refrigerator
about 30 minutes until it sets nicely we
have oreo cake white cake and
oreo buttercream my white cake is a
little bit dummy on the top so i'm going
to
trim a little bit using slated knife
give a little bit haircut and my oreo
cake
looks very even so i don't need to trim
it
i have a tongue table and
eight inch cake board tape so it doesn't
move around
first i'm gonna put oreo cake about half
a cup of buttercream
spread evenly put white cake upside down
and another half cup roasting and this
is going to be tall cake so
instead of frosting the side apart
at the end i'm frosting side now
now for the third layer another
chocolate cake
so when you cut it it kind of looks like
oreo if your buttercream
is too stiff you can add one tablespoon
milk to loosen it up spread evenly
and cover the sides the fourth layer
the white cake another half cup oreo
butter cream
the last layer oh my god it's scary
it's cake eats wobbly what if i cannot
make it fancy
the end of the show
[Laughter]
thank you everybody coming along my
journey
so when you are making tall cake like
this
make sure cake is completely cooled so
it doesn't fall
apart when you cool the cakes it's
become a little bit more stable
also you can use this kind of stick and
just stick
into the cake so make it very stable
i feel like cake making is pretty close
to
construction work because you kind of
paint the wall
carry heavy stuff mixing stuff like
cement
to use bench scraper to make it smooth
make sure you are not pushing too hard
hold lightly put the bench scraper 25
degrees
against the cake make sure your hand is
steady and not moving
and just move the tan table we are going
to put this in the refrigerator about 30
minutes
so oreo butter cream will set
i have oreo coral cookie
strawberries and raspberry for
decoration
white chocolate bark dark chocolate bark
and i have a little bit left
over oreo buttercream and i have
more oreos break some oreo bark
kind of going for abstract shape so
i want to break it a little longer
you can adjust the size later using
dab or buttercream as a glue it's kind
of improvised
design so i am
not sure how it's gonna turn out i'm
gonna just hope
it look beautiful and fancy
the nice thing about it it has a nice
hold
so you can still see nice oreo
speckled buttercream i'm using white
oreo bark
dark oreo bark right now it looks like
japanese armor
and it looks very cold there is no right
or wrong
so just follow your heart i want to
put some oreo i have a secret weapon
it's a gold spray just like spray
and dust it off i'm gonna use
couple raspberries just to make the
color pop
strawberries put some icing on the
strawberry and
just put around here so it doesn't roll
or the last
piece of coral and
we are done
[Music]
gothic avo struck oreo cake very fancy
alright time to give this a try this is
very tall
cake i just cut the small piece for
myself i have
white cake oreo cake oreo butter cream
oreo cookie and maybe i'm gonna eat
some of oreo bark
the cake is very moist it's not dry
cookies very crunchy and tasty
it cannot go any fancier than this
mountain fancy so inside is layer of
black and white so it just looks like
oreo
overall i'm so happy how it turned out i
highly recommend you to make a home
if you make a home please tag me on my
instagram
and don't forget to dance make it fancy
[Music]